hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host john carroll we've
talked about evolution several times on
the podcast in the past few months in
this calendar year 2022 and it's
something that we can just keep coming
back to over and over again and i love
talking about it because on the one hand
natural selection darwinian evolution
obviously true every scientifically
sensible person understands this it was
a tremendous insight that darwin came up
with into how species evolve how they
change over time but at the same time
huge controversies rage within the field
you can have a bunch of people who
completely agree on the basic outlines
of natural selection but have very very
strong and emotional reactions to
individual sub-questions within it
and they're real questions they're not
sort of fake questions and they're not
even way out at the speculative
periphery they're right at the heart of
the matter in the standard model of
particle physics we have a lot of
success it's obviously true in its
domain of dependence but
we don't have a lot of controversy over
the big questions right like no one's
really going to the mat over the value
of the fine structure constant or how
many quark flavors or colors there are
things like that hopefully we'll go
beyond the standard model but the
standard model itself is understood
whereas in evolution we can go to very
very basic questions such as the
relative role of randomness and luck
versus adaptation and convergence we had
on the podcast my namesake sean b
carroll who is a champion for taking
very seriously the idea that there's a
lot of randomness and luck that comes
into the evolution of life the basic
idea being of course individual species
and populations adapt to their
environments and their surroundings and
their competition and so forth but maybe
there are a lot of ways that could
happen and a lot of ways to get there
because the space of possible genomes is
incredibly big way way bigger than life
here on earth will ever actually explore
so contingency and randomness and
unpredictability play a big role in the
actual history of life in this view on
the other side we have people who think
look given the constraints of how
organisms and populations survive and
flourish within a certain environment
they're going to find very very similar
conclusions they're going to design
themselves be designed in this sort of
uh blind watchmaker kind of design sense
into more or less what works in that
particular regime and that's going to be
the same no matter how you got there
that's the adaptationist point of view
and we we had ari kirshenbaum and also
richard dawkins on the podcast recently
those folks are on that side today's
guest simon conway morris is a
distinguished paleontologist and
evolutionary biologist who is very much
on the adaptationist side of things so i
guess we're a little unbalanced this
year uh we have many adaptationists uh
this year but yeah that's okay it's an
interesting question to talk about and
uh simon conway morris is most well
known in scientific circles for his
exploration of the burgess shale this is
a fossil-bearing deposit that teaches us
a lot about the cambrian explosion the
cambrian explosion was this moment in
evolutionary history when a tremendous
number of new species came into
existence 500 million years ago
something like that and simon as i said
is a champion of this view that
evolution is converging onto the best
possible solution even though it might
get there from very different ways and
he has a new book out called from
extraterrestrials to animal minds six
myths of evolution so he's pushing
against some of the popular myths about
how evolution works and it's not you
know he's not fighting against
intelligent design or whatever but about
the role of mass extinctions the
difference between humans and other
animals things like that i will i will
keep his actual uh claims until the
actual podcast you can hear what he has
to say
the other very interesting thing from my
perspective about simon is that he is a
theistic evolutionist so unlike i think
it's fair to say unlike most
evolutionary biologists
uh he is a quite card-carrying religious
believer he believes in god and thinks
that god and evolution are perfectly
compatible with each other not my view
okay but it's always an interesting one
to come across and talk about with with
someone who really understands what
they're doing and is not too dogmatic
about things uh you know if i read what
simon writes in his book to me you know
there's little tiny elements of his
religious belief seeping in
not not like oh jesus did this something
like that but a comfort level with
purpose telos a special role for minds
in the cosmos a special role for
humanity whatever but the reason why i
think it's important to talk about is
because you know look a naturalist like
myself i'm sure that my views seep in to
other things that i say and the question
is where's the causality do i have these
big beliefs about the ontology of the
world because of my scientific
discoveries and understandings or vice
versa uh you know who knows i think that
the important thing is that we can get
together and talk about it and see
what's going on so occasional reminder
we have on here on mindscape a patreon
page where you can support the podcast
at patreon.com
sean m carroll and you can join up throw
in a dollar or so to every episode and
you get the right to listen to the
episodes ad free and also to ask
questions at the monthly amas and the
general warm feeling that you're part of
a pretty awesome community which i think
mindscape has grown up to be so thanks
very much and let's go
[Music]
simon conway morris welcome to the
mindscape podcast thank you so much
so evolution is something we've been
talking about a little bit on the
podcast in various directions uh there
are interesting sets of controversies
and issues uh unsolved problems within
not not between evolutionary biology and
non-evolutionary biology but even within
the specialty i mean what are you what
is your feeling about what are the
biggest uh
co i don't i don't even want to say
controversies but big questions or
divisions that the professionals are uh
talking about amongst themselves
well actually i'd step almost
immediately backwards and say that to
the first approximation sort of
darwinian thinking is is rather static
these days i mean you look at the great
majority of papers being published and
they're doing much the same things
they're doing 30 years ago what's really
changed of course courses technologies
and you know things like crisp and all
the rest of it um and i was when i give
lectures and i actually have to say
straight away i'm retired so i don't do
so many lecturing it's probably just
well for the world at large um i sort of
say well actually
in my view sort of biology evolutions
got into a little bit of a rut whereas
you know you think about those chaps of
cosmologists and physicists of course an
area you know a great deal about more
about and i do and you know look at them
and in the last 20 years they've managed
to lose 90 of the visible universe i
thought well well done they're really
making progress
and i usually cap that with that famous
quote from niels bohr which i i
mentioned in various places where he
says something along the lines of i
really like your idea i really do it's
absolutely crazy there's only one
problem it's not crazy enough
and so
within evolution there is if you like uh
paradigms and orthodoxies
and uh my new book um which of course i
shall publicize relentlessly as possible
um a wonderful read a wonderful read
he's trying to look at what i call myths
of evolution not areas which are um
fictional but ones where receive wisdom
in my view is overdue and here i use a
very english term very overdue for a
really good kicking i'm sorry no no what
i mean is time to reappraise them and so
for example um if we think about mass
extinctions very briefly uh we all know
about those we all know what happened in
fish lab we all know what happened at
cannes so combination asteroid impact
and massive volcanism in india leads to
very bad news all around the planet
farewell to dinosaurs here come the
mammals you and i are now talking in a
sense almost as a direct result of that
catastrophe because if the mammals
hadn't radiated then of course the
mammal the the dinosaurs i'm sorry would
have carried on as before and that would
have been more or less the end of the
story well i i'd actually disagree with
that and again i don't want to unpack
this in ghastly detail but there are a
couple of things worth remembering and
one is of course that the mammals were
co-existing with the dinosaurs they in
fact started to evolve seriously in fact
probably in the late jurassic some sort
of 90 million years before the asteroid
hit
more importantly they're actually
beginning to diversify and although the
traditional views of the cretaceous
scene are gigantic dinosaurs and things
which look like sort of scaled down mice
sort of you know shivering underneath
the ferns in point of fact some of the
mammals were getting quite large some
actually ate baby dinosaurs for
breakfast but more particularly the
mammals are sooner or later going to
take over the world in my my view and
indeed a book which has just been
published got very good reviews i
haven't read it yet myself by steve
brazati um looks at in fact the whole
story of the mammalian radiations but to
the first approximation
and here it's not quite as simple as
that but mammals are more social they're
warm-blooded and they tend to have
bigger brains and by and large that's a
sort of winning combination and another
thing some groups do as indeed in a
convergent way do the birds is they also
make tools and sooner or later in my
view and i can unpack this a bit further
if you're interested then a dinosaur
being wandering through a glade and
there'd been a thud of a spear in its
side the mammals have turned up dinner
time
well you know so
yeah
no that that's actually great and it's a
little bit out of order for what i was
thinking but it's just so juicy and good
that i would love to unpack some of
these details here so
you're not so that one of your myths in
the book is let's get the title of the
book out there uh for the listeners from
extraterrestrials to animal minds six
bits of evolution
so one of the myths is a is labeled uh
mass extinctions and so you're not
saying that the myth is that there were
mass extinctions you're agreeing with
that right absolutely absolutely how
could you look they're bad
don't go there
right very but in the long term don't
worry
right if you're a mammal that well
that's the interesting thing so is this
a general lesson that you're suggesting
that
the changes that happened subsequent to
mass exchange extinctions largely would
have happened anyway
they would have happened on the time
scale we know because there was a mass
extinction but effectively what i would
suggest is that paradoxically and i like
paradoxes a bit like niels bohr i
suppose um
mass extinctions actually accelerate
something they give you roughly 50
million years for free so in other words
instead of the grunt work of you know
working way up um slowly slowly slowly
which would have been the case if
there'd not been a mass extinction uh in
point of fact then getting rid of the
dinosaurs was terribly helpful of course
lots of reptiles survived snakes lizards
all that sort of thing but it gave them
they gave the mammals a leg up which
they they enjoyed but otherwise i have a
counterfactual which simply says well
other things which happen on this planet
apart from mass extinctions which are
roughly every 200 million years are
glaciations every now and again they
every now and again they go completely
out of control and we call that a
snowball earth but mostly the ones we
have at the end of the ordovician
in the carboniferous and the permian and
the one we're in at the present day um
uh glaciate the the the the poles so
what happens in this counterfactual
world the world the the planet begins to
refrigerate uh in what we call a legacy
probably about 30 million years after
the asteroid which never struck
and of course in that temperate zone and
polar zone you can get a handful of
reptiles but this is just sort of place
which
would provide in my view a sort of
stimulus
for innovation amongst the mammals so
the history would not be the same why
should it be but the end result is
almost indistinguishable
is there any chance in your mind that
the dinosaurs would have instead gotten
better right you rather than mammals
catching up and overtaking them that
dinosaurs would have become tool users
and become more intelligent
well dale russell um who was a very sort
of talented
paleontologist suggested much that in
much in as much as he sort of thought
about this sort of theropod-like
dinosaur which it became more and more
what we call encephalitis larger brain
and managed to manipulate things it was
bipedal so it had hands and all the rest
of it but in a certain way your
question's already answered because of
course dinosaurs did exactly what you
asked them to do they turn into birds
right and if we look at the parallels
and the convergences between the birds
in all sorts of ways with the mammals um
including tool making such as we might
see in a new caledonian crow and again
we have to unpack tool making perhaps
slightly further down the line it's not
quite what it appears to be etc etc etc
um then in in that way they are
feathered dinosaurs and if they suffer a
i i worry about saying disadvantage
because by and large biology is a genius
of getting around problems is that they
never give birth to live young
with one possible exception
it is reported this is i mentioned in a
previous book that of course they lay
eggs and the eggs hatch and so forth
but in some lizards for example
effectively the uh eggs hatch within the
the female and you have live birth and
you have the same thing in some fish as
it so happens so this is what we call
the arab
vivid parity um but apart from this sort
of rather mysterious
budgerigar in a town in england called
dorking and anybody's england will know
what i'm talking about it apparently did
give life to it gave birth to live
budget goals it's so ridiculous we won't
worry about it so there we are they they
they do lots of things very similar to
mammals if you look at the crows and the
parrots they have really quite large
brains in proportion to their body mass
etc etc yeah sure
well it's interesting because this
relates to one of the
controversies or sets of issues that i
wanted to get into which was the famous
one that you've been very active in in
arguing on one side for about if we
played the tape of life backwards uh if
we played it again how similar would the
outcomes be and there's certainly an
argument that you know look there are
niches that need to be filled and
they're going to be filled one way or
the other uh i mean maybe you can
explain in your words the state of play
within the field about that particular
set of issues sort of randomness and
drift versus adaptation to specific sets
of niches
thank you well i find myself deeply
surprised to be saying the following
words which is i think more and more
people are agreeing with this view
that what we call evolutionary
convergence that is starting from
different points in the tree of life and
ending up with very much the solution
the same solution in point of fact it's
something which is not only ubiquitous
but really underpins a great deal of
what's going on in evolution in other
words and again i always sort of
hesitate when i
talk to physicists of any description
but if you think about the potential
number of the combinatorial immensity of
biological space it's just stupidly
large i mean with great respect here i
think you chaps deal with fairly small
change you know what is it 10 to 90
basic particles in the visible units and
that means something like that you know
not too many whereas when you go to
biology the potential number of
alternatives simply because of the
combinatorics is just enormously large
and therefore that may we proceed to
another part of the conversation on some
other planet there will be life and it
may indeed be cellular and so forth but
in all other respects it would be
genuinely alien
whereas what we see here on this planet
is that by and large
convergences are seen across the board
and in particular most of those are just
the routine sorts of things which oddly
enough darwin never really dealt with
him he he acknowledges it but i suspect
because in the sense he was trying to
move away from the earlier 19th century
religious establishment creationism
he wanted to have everything going in
all possible directions in other words
nothing was constrained by some master
plan which might be sort of deep deeply
concealed in the fabric of life
so whether that's the case or not
i'm sort of interested in what is the
likelihood of let us say eyes evolving
very high as mike land has pointed out
what is a possibility of other sensory
systems evolving very high it's a good
idea to be able to detect molecules
which land on an epithelium and are
converted into the smell of a white wine
we approve of that of course
but one of the curious things which is
slightly oblique to this is it turns out
if you go and look at the insects
they also have the capacity for what we
call olfaction that is they can smell
things for very good reason like finding
humans to feed on their blood and all
this good stuff here however
it turns out that actually the molecule
they use which effectively acts as a as
a way of transferring the physical
stimulus of the molecule arriving to the
electrical signal the transduction if
you like um is based on on on a
particular protein arrangement we don't
have to go into all the ghastly details
but it it's it's actually something
which looks identical to what we use for
our old faction and indeed in our other
sensory systems but blow me down it's
completely independent and nobody knows
why
why
did it throw away a perfectly good
system but the constraint is such that
if you want to have an
ability to smell something you've got to
use this protein and there's a similar
argument with other enzymes which
accelerate various chemical reactions
and i think that suggests that there is
a fundamental predictability to
evolution both at a molecular level but
also all the way up to the development
of large brains warm-bloodedness
manipulability
and precision grip and all those sorts
of things um and collectively they would
suggest that in my view overall
something akin to a human is pretty
likely to evolve on most planets
that's very interesting yeah ir
kirshenbaum made a very similar uh
argument he's very interested in exactly
that issue but let me i forgot to ask
him i did ask richard dawkins and he he
thought it was an interesting question
but wasn't sure what the answer was
certainly the combinatorics of our
genome is such that you can imagine huge
numbers of different uh ways the dna
could be arranged and we're never ever
going to explore even most of that space
right it's just too big
there's also a big space of possible
morphologies of bodies of various
organisms but what is what is the
mapping between that like is there
enough room in genome space to give us
just about any
organic morphology for an organism that
we would want you know can we can we
tweak the genome of a human being to
give it a tentacle or something like
that or how much do we know about that
well
i'm not surprised richard dawkins uh you
know says well let's we need to think
about this i think that there are a
number of difficulties with approaching
that question in as much as there is not
simply a direct connection between the
genome and morphology if you knock out
parts of the gene then you will often
have some embryonic disaster but in
point of fact sometimes when you abuse
the genome in various ways there are all
sorts of rescue mechanisms whereby the
form can then be re-expressed and of
course you know there are very famous
experiments for instance using the gene
which is involved with eye development
where if you over express it then on the
insect you have something which is
really frankenstein in my view and as
much as the eyes develop on the legs and
on the wings and all sorts of places
where you don't normally see eyes but i
think beyond that
there is a sort of cohesiveness to the
form which is obviously underpinned by
the genome
but the genome in itself is you know
as dawkins himself has explained is you
know it's it's just a way of making
information which is then transcribed
through much more complex processes um
so i'm not trying to dodge the question
too seriously uh it's more that in a
sense uh if you look at the fundamentals
of the genome and the codons the sorts
of things which are responsible for the
for the amino acids the 64 variants on
that there is some reason to think that
actually our genetic code which is found
on this planet
is not your bog standard one it is
fantastically good it really is
exceptional uh there may be better ones
yes but even so this one seems to do
what we needed to do and on that basis
given that actually the way in which the
uh well that if you look at
single-celled organisms for instance by
and large they have very very complex
genomes
and the prediction was that when the
human genome was going to be analyzed
they said oh we reckon around about a
hundred thousand maybe two hundred
thousand genes and what's the total well
twenty one thousand thereabouts and the
reason for that in part is because uh
evolution hasn't got time on its hands
things are streamlined they're
economized they're all sorts of
shortcuts taken and probably perhaps to
build something as complex as ourselves
you simply in embryology don't have the
capacity to deal with 100 000 genes
you've got to streamline the whole
section and you can think of analogies
and technology of course
yeah and as a physicist the idea that
keeps coming to mind is equilibrium
versus non-equilibrium dynamics here
because i'm wondering how often in
evolution we get to a situation where
the ecosystem like the whole set of
different populations have filled their
niches and is more or less static versus
things are highly dynamic and eventually
everything will change i mean
is it really true that everything is
always changing although sometimes it
might be too slow for us to see
i i think
i mean my view
in a sort of way is it's rather ironic
that here the first species which can
actually look around the world and say
isn't this extraordinary and we might
come onto that in a later context
actually moved into a biosphere which is
probably the most diverse which the
planet had ever seen and there were a
number of reasons for this uh partly
because of the climatic sort of the
variability which has been
characteristic for the last 30 million
years with you know pretty cool areas
and warm equators and so forth and all
the rest of it
but but more particularly um you know
you get things like a rainforest now
rainforests actually appear in the time
of the dinosaurs
and in that sort of sense this is
something which in a way in its own way
can accommodate an enormous amount of
diversity and a similar argument applies
to the coral reefs and things like that
and of course subsequent to that because
we turned up and admired all this by
biodiversity and then decided a good
part of it might be better put in zoos
or put in farms and all the rest of it
and by the way i'm not you know i'm not
going down any particular lines of
argument here the trouble is that if you
have a sapient species
then all bets are off after that there's
not a lot we can necessarily do about it
other than to be responsible uh but i'm
not going to preach about that either
all the rest so
there is some suggestion
that in a way not only is the world as
diverse as it ever was going to be but
in point of fact for various reasons i
think we've probably reached the limits
of what is possible and you can approach
it in all sorts of different directions
but there are i think upper limits on
well things like body size and so forth
but more more particularly a very nice
papers this take it's not technical
stuff but if you look at a lobster
turn it upside down and you've got a set
of appendages some for walking some for
feeding some for respiration and so
forth so they're specialized as you look
along the length of the body now we
assume that the
er lobster which was much more primitive
had a more or less identical set of
appendages along its length they did
basically one or two things but as time
goes on they get more and more
specialized well um some years ago
colleagues of mine in bath university
actually then analyzed whether there was
any more latitude for further
differentiation and they came to the
conclusion no it's more or less reached
the limits of what is possible
and what i find so intriguing of course
is that i think this applies for
instance to brain size and in point of
fact with a human brain you can argue
it's a pretty grotesque thought but it's
pretty close to what is absolutely
possible in terms of the different
growth rates of what we call the white
matter and the gray matter
it can get a bit bigger but not not that
much older but of course the crucial
difference
is that in a sense of brain size isn't
so much the question now it is because
we now see the world in an utterly
different way in part scientific in part
artistic and so on and so forth and in
that sort of way we have unlimited
potentiality it's rather ironic you know
we come from a group of primates closely
related to chimpanzee what are they
doing well with great respect not very
much what are we doing we're talking to
each other
right right and actually this just
reminds me i'm going to ask again
because now i'm more educated since the
past 20 minutes you've helped me
in the evolution of human or mammals
versus dinosaurs um i i think that i
would i'm willing to buy the idea that
there is
well sorry
let me just back up and not just buy the
idea but ask you about it do you think
that over the course of evolution there
is a tendency towards more overall
complexity in the biosphere
careful mortimer careful
he's asking you a tricky question
yeah well yes yes i think there is
but complexity well again you're the
expert because the physicists know what
they're talking about i don't a
complexity is deceptive
and something which you know looks
exceedingly complex like a single-celled
organism at one level is more complex if
you like and i have written a little bit
on this actually devising a metric for
complexity and biology is
extraordinarily difficult one has a sort
of intuitive
sense of what it might be
but
overall yes my sense is that the degree
of ecological integration for instance
the interdependence of of of different
forms and one of my favorite examples um
is that if you're going to be an insect
you want to eat okay very good idea um
some insects the aphids actually
penetrate the the surface of the plant
and extract sugary sap well you know
that's not an ideal diet but heck you
know if they get by but there's another
groups of related forms and what they do
because just to remind your listeners
because a plant is basically a set of
tubes some which are taking sugars to to
from the leaves down to the rest of the
plant and from the roots the water is
ascending to provide the necessary
underpinning of photosynthesis so these
insects what do they do they drink the
water in the center of the plant what we
call the xylem tubes now i mean
as as a source of nutrition uh to speak
technically this is bonkers absolutely
bonkers nobody in their right mind
because there are in fact traces of
organic material in it but that doesn't
bother them because they ingest colossal
quantities of water to extract that but
within their bodies they have a
consortium of bacteria
and they are the ones who do a lot of
the heavy lifting when it comes to
synthesizing things like the amino acids
and there's the way these amino acids
the way these uh bacteria are intriguing
integrated together is totally
staggering i mean the degree of
interpenetration of molecular pathways
of one separate species of bacteria is
is staggering now if that isn't complex
i don't know what is and there is reason
to think that that's more or less reach
the limits of what is possible
well that's exactly why i think it's an
interesting question because uh you're
completely right that no one agrees on
how to define complexity or certainly
has a
a way that is completely robust and can
be shared but there's a kind of
operational question when it comes to
evolutionary biology which is when is a
certain ecosystem
in equilibrium when does it fit all of
the niches that are around it and will
would stay that way for 100 million
years if you let it versus when is it
just creeping very slowly but 100
million years later it's going to look
completely different is that the kind of
thing that evolutionary biologists worry
about
i hope they don't worry about it um
my i mean in the end
this is not an area which i can claim
any expertise whatsoever but my limited
understanding about it in a way is that
you can't really separate the organism
in a niche because the organism makes a
niche and also
to the very first approximation yes if
you live on a mountain or you live in an
oceanic trench there are considerable
physical constraints and you adapt to
those but otherwise most of the
conversation is not doing it's not
dealing with the sort of the the the the
day-to-day facts that there's sunlight
or darkness or wetness or drought those
things are handled because first of all
the organisms to the first approximation
show this amazing homeostasis you know
they have this ability to semi insulate
themselves from the vicissitudes of the
environment
and in all other respects what they're
doing the whole time is either learning
how to eat each other learning how to
live together learning how to interact
learning how to communicate and of
course when you go to bacterial systems
there are all sorts of fascinating
stories whereby they are communicating
uh using various molecules and if you
have a plant which has been attacked by
an insect it will release volatiles
which inform nearby plants that they
might want to bolster their defenses
against the insects so the whole thing
is there's this enormous
communication racket
going across
all the biosphere everybody and here i
use my words with with lack of suitable
care
are interdependent on each other
but okay good i i get all that that's
very helpful and it allows me to finally
uh revisit the dinosaur question um is
there a plausible counterfactual history
in which
the mammals continued on there's there
was no great uh catastrophe there's no
um asteroid or volcano uh but both the
dinosaurs and the mammals sort of
flourished but the dinosaurs became the
intelligent dominant tool-using species
like if there's a niche for having a
bigger brain i mean maybe a different
species could have gotten it or maybe a
little genetic tweak could have helped
them give live birth i don't know
yeah no that's an extremely fair
question and in a way i've got i've got
all sorts of you know off the record
interest one is counter factual
histories
including you know historical things
like what would happen in gettysburg or
uh other battles have gone one way or
the other um and so in a certain way and
this is i hope not entirely trying to
dodge your question is i don't actually
care
who does it perfectly obviously i have a
parochial interest as a mammal but if i
was a dispassion observer visiting this
planet for the first time of course we
might get onto that and that will never
happen but don't worry um then you know
all i'm interested really is you're
going to need to have some sort of quote
warm bloodedness
but given that that's evolved numerous
times including its effective equivalent
in plants for heaven's sake
and that's a under there's a basic
physiological process there it's
actually ironically it's it's a
darwinian process which doesn't work and
because it doesn't work it's inefficient
and therefore it generates heat so there
we go so
so i would i'd like some more
bloodedness i certainly want some
increase in brain size some degree of
manipulability would be good and you can
see what for instance some parents do
with with their beaks and then their
claws you know they're pretty adept at
moving things around so
in that sort of way i really don't mind
all i would say is you know i'm going to
put my money on something which will
ultimately be sapient
and able to make tools and not only make
tools but make tools to make other tools
and that is one but by no means the only
crucial crucial distinction between
ourselves and other animals well you've
done an excellent job of leading us into
the next great myth that i wanted to
talk about which are the animal minds um
you know you don't want to say that it's
a myth that animals have minds they do
but they're different and i think if
it's fair to say you want to
push against the recent tendency to
lower the differences between animal
minds and human minds you want to really
emphasize that there is kind of a shift
in kind not just in magnitude about how
we think is that fair
um yes indeed it's it's not the sort of
thing which makes for a successful
career so i recommend if you think about
this sort of thing do it when you've
retired
and indeed the orthodoxies are very much
and you mentioned you've been talking to
francois and amongst other people quite
recently and i would imagine he would
find some difficulty agreeing with his
point of view and
from his perspective with very good
reason indeed um
and again i have to emphasize i'm not
for a moment disputing the evolutionary
continuity between ourselves and at the
common ancestor which would say seven
million years ago and all restaurant
but
uh
partly inspired by a number of books
including one by thomas sudendorff
who i've not met but his chap works in
australia on on he's got
on animal minds um he's got this book
called the gap
and he's by no means alone in this there
are a number of other workers who you
know are
skeptical they don't generally unpack it
in any sort of metaphysical sense and
perhaps that's a very sensible thing not
to do
but in essence the more i've read into
this area the more struck i've been by a
whole set of observations about what
animals can and cannot do
and people will say as indeed darwin did
of course in his descent of man it's
simply a matter of a
qualitative difference it's a slightly
bigger brain it's a reorganization of
the genome it's bigger social units and
any one of those may indeed be the
explanation
but um what what struck me very much is
that
in a way where in fact i was just
looking at paper the other day and this
may seem entirely tangential
it's paper and proc roy sock as we call
it and it's something to do again with
our old friends of reese's monkeys
and
this particular one if you read the fine
print in these papers and they're very
generous because they give you the fine
print they actually explain the
experimental protocol and the first
thing of course is the animal must be
trained
animals very seldom are spontaneous and
sort of just pick up something and
wander off and do it for you and in a
way which is actually contrasts very
markedly with even young children
and but the second thing is the degree
of training is staggering i mean
typically speaking it will take
50 000 trials
to eventually
persuade the animal to do what you want
it to because you can't tell it and the
reason for that which actually think is
related because they can't speak right
they can hear commands of course that's
okay they're not stupid as you say in
their own context they are as bright as
they need to be
but there was one particular example
which to do again with reese's monkeys
where these people wanted to find out
whether they could uh engage in
entrainment
and there's no good me clicking my
fingers like this because i can't dance
to save my life any case so much from
the despair of my wife but that's
another story um that that they so they
use a metronome and they change the
pictures of it and so forth they want to
find out can the rhesus monkey entrain
to these changing sounds
and after a year
of relentless investigation they come to
the conclusion no they can't now we do
know some animals especially uh that
cockatoo called snowball i think it was
which is you know more or less hopping
around on its perch there's a fabulous
bit of of filming of this creature but
animals don't dance by and large and in
the case of these rhesus monkeys they
told me something extremely important
they told me not much about rhesus
monkeys it told me it told me a great
deal about us
in other words as i say in various
contexts what other species would
actually think this is an interesting
thing to do
you have to take your hat off to these
people
and then
there's another area and stop me
immediately if i'm going too far off
piece but with animal experimentation um
there are all sorts of uh of
explorations of cognitive prowess
and we know that the crows in particular
show some very striking convergences
with the more advanced mammals and one
of their party tricks goes back to um
what's
called the esops fable whereby you've
got a thirsty crow and it drops pebbles
into the container
which raises the level of water so you
can get a drink so this is this is
archimedes with feathers on okay oh very
good indeed and indeed it is very
striking that they learn fast
but they do have to be trained and sure
enough they drop things in
and they raise the level of water they
get their tip bit however if you make
things a little bit more complicated
like for instance having youtubes which
are concealed beneath
the surface of the platform where the
tubes are sticking out
even a fairly young child will quite
quickly learn out and learn about cause
and effect the crows never
never
they will do it by trial and error and
there's nothing wrong with that
but they don't seem to have any
substrate of rationality they can't
interrogate the world as something which
actually has if you like invisible
consequences to it they are to the first
approximation completely visible
it's a very interesting uh parallel
actually with a podcast i recently did
with judea pearl who's an expert in
causality and he makes exactly the same
point that a young baby
like very very young human beings are
constantly probing the world to learn
about its cause and effect relationships
and a computer won't right the ais do
not do that and so ai's can are much
better at chess and go than we are
but they don't have this instinct for
making a causal map of the world with
that is somehow embedded even very young
humans
that's that's that's that seems to be
the case and i i i can continue this
path of destruction if you so wish but
or or conversation if you prefer um but
another aspect which strikes me very
powerfully again entirely based on
reading of other people's papers um is
that animals also learn they have to
but they never teach
and the reason is of course that they
cannot enter the mind of the companion
and realize that the pupil has a mind
which can assimilate knowledge
so we have a chimpanzee and as it
happens the boys go off and hunt colabus
monkeys and a whole bag of stories there
and that's often described as warfare
and so forth it's not that at all but
that's a yet a slightly different story
that the female chimpanzees
in some but by no means all groups um
get large rocks and bring them down
firmly and smash open nuts and they get
the interior and that's all very helpful
it's it's rich in nutrients good good
good
the young chimpanzee
sitting beside the mother will observe
and it's not stupid but unfortunately it
will probably take that chimpanzee the
best part of three years to learn how to
do it
and the reason being of course that the
mother can't sort of correct the the
thing say no darling don't do it that
way move your foot out the way you clot
go
come on stop fooling around no we'll
have tea later et cetera et cetera et
cetera and this is something the only
really good example of teaching in
animals oddly enough is in ants and
that's a slightly sort of a big story
uh so there's another famous example to
do the meerkats
and um the young amongst the other
things they're going to have to learn
how to deal with the scorpions
and you know once you know how to deal
with them they're probably i guess
they're pretty tasty actually but of
course you've got to be aware of what's
at one end of the scorpion
so that's absolutely fine and initially
the young pups are given dead scorpions
to play with then subsequently they're
given scorpions which are being defanged
so to speak so they're safe-ish and only
later on are they uh adept enough to
deal with the real object
but it turns out that the levels of
instruction are entirely dependent on
the sounds which the pups make
so if you feed the wrong sound to the uh
to the tutor the usually the female i
believe it will assume the pup has a
level of understanding which is simply
doesn't because it is being misled
by the sound it makes so in other words
it can't go back into the mind of its
pupil
and this again is something which is so
difficult for us to place ourselves
outside the context we find ourselves in
because you know you and i know
perfectly well in universities we love
teaching and it's wonderful when you
sometimes very often first of all the
pupil gets it oh god i see it now and
then it's even more terrifying because
they come back the following day and say
i've been thinking about this a bit more
have you thought of doing it this way no
no no you know you're out you know
you're
you're
you're you're past your pass your sale
by date come on give way to the young
person
yeah they keep making new young
scientists it's very frustrating
sometimes yeah no no it's very
satisfying there was a moment where i
thought i knew all that people in my
field and it went by very quickly um
you know look let me just get my own
feelings here on the table which is that
i don't have any strong feelings about
animal minds versus human minds on on
the one hand i i do perceive that there
is this
constant refrain of human beings saying
animals can't do x and then we discover
an animal doing x but then i also see
which i think is the point you're making
that when we dig into what's really
going on in x it's a much simpler more
direct call and response kind of thing
than it would be in the analogous human
situation where there's some abstraction
and reasoning going on so
and also i do look around and see that
human beings like you say have done
things that animals haven't done so
there has to be some difference if we
can just put our finger on sure
no i i i i agree of course i mean it and
and that this is this is a risky area
because some people might then say well
if animals you know really aren't human
and so forth we can treat them you know
pretty well as we like and
i couldn't disagree more strongly i mean
the very fact that we are aware if you
like of their predicament
means that you know
in a certain sense they i mean this
sounds very patronizing it's not meant
to be that at all but they they we have
a dogs it so happens and maybe you have
pets as well but you know as you get to
associate them with you you know that as
you say they're conscious they've got
minds they've got emotions and all the
rest of it but uh in the case of this
smart doctor spaniel i'm afraid to say
you know it's quite clear it's got it's
got focused idea what we're talking
about if i give it a command it
sometimes does what i ask
um and i i think beyond that
i then sort of want to say well why the
difference is it just you know that we
we've got
smarter by accident and you know people
use examples like dolphins and in
particular and something which is
convergent or a parrot or a crow is more
encouraging but in all these cases not
only is there a crucial difference and
not everybody will agree with me on this
point of course that they they can't
teach but they don't speak
they vocalize
but once again
we under appreciate because it's so
completely familiar to us that our
language isn't just a set of sounds
which have quote a
they are completely cognitive right you
know we cannot we there's some very
interesting sort of counter examples of
this one or two groups in the brazilian
jungles for instance
which interestingly don't have the
otherwise standard feature of language
which we call recursion whereby you can
embed meaning within meaning within
meaning
and as i understand it what's so
fascinating about these
people is that they're fully human in
all respects but they have no history
they have no folklore
and again as a as an evolution biologist
one is fascinated as
what was the environment perhaps where
they didn't in a sense need this
because in all other respects you know
they're absolutely attuned to their very
well attuned to their environment um
and there are very famous examples the
best known still is the vervet monkeys
and they have these um alarm calls one
for snake and one for leopard and one
for an eagle and at first sight this
seems to me you know this is a proto
word but in point of fact for a whole
set of lines of investigation um this
this is i think is generally not
accepted by anybody now that they're
communicating that's beyond a shadow of
doubt but
there's no suggestion any more than
there is with birdsong you might think
well birdsong very complex lots and lots
of noises often terraria is very
mellifluous
and what's it do well to the very first
approximation it's either say go away or
come closer
and they never export that
in a set of different meanings so it's
it's again not a language and
again this is going into dangerous
territory but it and here we go you know
i can see you reaching for the off
button here i think this has been very
good professional i think we'll just
draw this to halt now
what is on the nature of our
consciousness and and this is you know
this is the graveyard of ambition well
yeah i mean look again
my own view is there's a lot of
unanswered questions here but it's fun
to talk about them and in fact let's
let's just assume let's just take for
the sake of discussion the idea that
there is a difference in kind between
human minds and animal minds how without
necessarily saying if it's true let's
assume it's true and move on um yeah how
would we characterize it you know from
reading your book and also from a lot of
other things i i can sort of try to boil
it down to
two things one is a capacity for
abstraction
and the other is a capacity for
counterfactual reasoning as we talked
about before and both of these are
involved with language uh is that your
feeling also or do you think there's
other thing other ingredients that i've
missed
i i think they're part of the
ingredients and in a certain way a
little bit like the the weasel word
complexity uh so to the weasel word
abstraction
and you know clearly you know you've got
an understanding mathematics which i
will never have i understand that
perfectly well
um in an ironic an ironic sort of way
but it is in a sense that we we have
this unlimited potentialities
and this is what i find so fascinating
about anything to do with
in a sense
summoning the invisible now you correct
me immediately but i was and and i i
always like talking to people who are
experts in areas and you mentioned a
particular paper they saw uh yes yeah
yeah yeah no yeah it's still red yes yes
you know thank you very much but gene
weakness paper about the unreasonable
factors of some mathematics it certainly
quoted the title a lot and no one reads
it but they quote the title
oh i've read it it's quite short i
highly recommend it it's very short yeah
it's very easy very readable and i
understood it
after a fashion but if i remember
correctly amongst other things and
you'll have to explain to me what it is
it's you know the complex number and so
forth this is something which doesn't in
any sort of you know in any serious
sense exist well it does
but you know you can write it down and
you know and so forth but as soon as you
let it loose into your equations off it
goes
and does things which otherwise would
not have been possible i think this is
this fair
roughly and there's much many more
arguments no that's exactly his argument
and you're right there are many more
examples of
kinds of mathematical structures that
seem so abstract and you know we would
not have bumped into them in the jungles
and yet
we
come across them in our mathematical
explorations and find that they describe
physical reality really well and so
that's the mystery that he wanted to
point to i'm a little skeptical of this
a mystery i think that expos facto
whatever reality was doing we would have
invented the correct mathematics to
describe it uh but there is a point
there about how the world works in very
orderly patterned mathematical ways
yes but the fact if i understand you
correctly that we've got there one way
or the other in a way and yes from that
perspective and i'm not i'm no expert on
the history of mathematics at all and of
course one knows uh all sorts of
different traditions of indian and
islamic and so forth and all the rest of
it but then you say you go back to an
animal
and i i think this is true i mean one of
my favorite examples is
the parrots have been used quite
extensively um by various people and and
with a huge amount of effort you get you
can more or less get them to understand
at two plus three and they tap it you
know a bit like a seance i suppose it
comes out with the answer five very good
okay and then you say uh and what is six
plus zero and they'll say oh no that's
an easy one seven
i don't know that i was not aware but uh
yeah
it's there's a set of mysteries there
and also about whether math is real or
not that i again these are good
questions i i wish i had more strong
opinions about them
well i i don't think i have strong
opinions about in a certain sense i
don't have strong opinions about
anything it's it's more i just you know
one wants to be
one wants to sort of challenge things if
you like and just say well hang on a
moment this is now received wisdom you
know everybody's nodding their head
and
quite frequently in in a whole a set of
areas and i've got we better not go into
this area otherwise all sorts of
terrible things will happen but you know
there's a certain sense do you agree
that actually
in many areas of life um including even
science there are there are imposed
conformities
and sort of thinking out of the box is
not necessarily encouraged
and it's difficult because you generally
have to work in large teams you're
dependent on grant income there are all
sorts of constraints on your life these
days but you know in the case of the
animal mind business actually um and i i
don't have the paper immediately to hand
but there's a reason it's actually on
the on the archive series you know it's
not actually it's not peer-reviewed and
normal arrested but gently pointing out
in in reality the the reliability of a
lot of this experimental work is
it's not it's not false or fake or or
dishonest or any way but it just suffers
from enormous difficulties the groups
are quite small
uh nearly all the animals they work with
not all but many of them are what we
call enculturated that is they have
lived in close association with humans
and we know that they are smarter by and
large and so you have these spectacular
case examples of you know sign language
and all the rest of it but onion is this
very intensive training but these aren't
the sort of things they do
in the in the wild and one such example
is to do with what's called mirror
self-recognition right and you know you
and i i mean i don't know about you
these days but when i look in the mirror
in the white house say this is not too
good at all
you must drink less you must drink much
less etc etc and indeed there are some
animals which seem to have this ability
to recognize themselves whereby you put
a mark on them and then they start you
know metaphorically speaking doing this
scratching of the forehead and so forth
but
almost without exception these are
animals which are enculturated
so they've been in human contact often
for years so you when you go to the
jungle you never see a chimpanzee
looking into a pool of water saying well
i'm a handsome chap you know gosh yeah
a haircut perhaps but you know
and that again tells me something that
that going back to your question about
the limits of what they can do
you can take them that much further if
they're in association with us and in
its own way that's very satisfying i
mean why are pets so popular
you know who would who in their right
mind would bring into a household full
of children
a carnivore
full of parasites
yeah but that that's bonzo
[Laughter]
all right it's a rhetorical question we
know the answer but it's it's a very
human kind of thing to do but you know i
i can imagine as a complete non-expert
that there was some kind of phase
transition some kind of
uh little
change that led to a large outcome you
know certainly the theory of computation
and mathematics we have these examples
where you add another axiom to your
system and suddenly it's immensely more
powerful and i can imagine
that there was a transition
from other primate brains to the human
brains that gave us levels of
abstraction or counterfactual thinking
that really made a difference do you
think that there's some prospect for
locating such things physically in the
brain as we understand the human brain
more and more
not a hope okay
i'll tell you why for various reasons um
what this again is it goes back to this
tricky question um
it's it in effect that there are various
sorts of what are known as hydrocephaly
uh these are whereby substantial amounts
of brain tissue are missing and and
that's the sinuses are greatly enlarged
and there are some cases it's not a
simple um a simple area at all but every
now and again somebody turns up for a
routine scan
in the hospital they might have
something you know not something not
quite red with the with the feeling in
the head and they find out they've got a
thin layer of neural tissue and they've
hardly got a brain at all right
um and that tells me something
again that you know it's not the breath
the brain if you like is essential in
the sense that it's there to conduct
things but it itself is not the seat of
it
if you like and another story which is
very haunting in a way because it's so
widespread now and this again is simply
on my reading is alzheimer's
and you know this is
we all know from our people we know it's
a very extraordinary distressing it's
just you know it's just ghastly but not
infrequently so i read towards the end
of the life of these people um they
actually enter a time of so-called
terminal lucidity
where suddenly all their memories come
back
and they're almost as if they were
before the alzheimer's developed
and as you say there may be some final
stage in the reorganization of the brain
tissue which leads to if you like a
reverse phase change
and similarly you can say well how much
neural tissue you actually need to do
these things but i would find those less
easy to to accept and again
it's well
there's a
like so many of these areas and
orthodoxy that it is the mind is just
material and is within the brain
but persistently over actually a number
of centuries but i think more recently
there are some people are saying well
come on this is just ridiculous we're
not getting anywhere with this one at
all
and not only are there cases of
hydrocephaly there are sometimes cases
and these are less common now for very
good reasons but really drastic brain
surgery even the removal of half the
brain
which you know in terms of animal
organization would be catastrophic
but not necessarily
but um
and i see you know probably times
getting on and your patients more more
than anybody else's but the way we're
going to answer all this of course is to
find an extraterrestrial so ask me about
that good that was exactly what i was
gonna ask you you're clearly seeing
where we're going here okay so this is
another one of your myths
extraterrestrials but what exactly is
the myth that you want to puncture about
extraterrestrials
well the wrong journey right
okay and so the myth is that they're
might sorry the myth is that they're
molly said i mean again you know you
know
look at the look look at the deep field
photographs you know
so many galaxies and all the rest of it
part of my thinking here again as ever
derived from other people is that there
is no evidence of any visitation of any
sort and even a fossil record would not
be a silly place to start looking after
all why not
or is there any evidence of signals well
there's that famous wow
right all those years ago but the most
recent evidence suggests it really was a
nearby sort of satellite um but it's
something which charlie lineweaver as an
astronomer in australia pointed out and
i think a number of other people have as
well too it's the first approximation
the solar system we inhabit is
relatively young it's about four and a
half billion years old
whereas there are many other solar
systems which pre-date hours by some
billions of years
and we have every reason to think
possess earth-like planets
and
and you have to accept a big and if
indeed they have life
yes if they have evolution of course and
if they're likely to end up with a
thinking dinosauroid i don't really mind
you know but as long as it's sapient and
all the rest of it then they've got a
head start of
two billion years yeah and if you assume
they want to go walk about
one paper head suggested that actually
going around the galaxy takes maybe 100
million years
not that long so where are they as
enrico firm has famously asked you know
what's going on and there's a book by
stephen webb uh which is i was re his
second edition quite recently on this
where i had i think 72 different
explanations
they blow themselves up yeah you know
they their their health costs go through
the roof it doesn't really matter which
one you want but
it's none really seem to quite be
sufficient to explain given the the
humongous number
of planets
do they all fall at some stage
and nothing and search for dyson spheres
you know the the idea you've got a super
advanced technology which actually
starts to harness most of the stellar
output
and if you look at you know mad but
plausible ideas for the whole galaxy
and you know you'll understand much
better night with regard to the
astronomy of infrared detection and
everything else that's something
astronomers do rather well and they have
indeed been searches not extensive but
of whole you know whole
groups of galaxies so it's not just
stars
but you know really big numbers being
looked at for anomalies nothing
occasional maybe question mark but
you know so what's going on here and
then i don't know are we allowed to talk
about these things i'm just looking at a
newspaper thing here because
your um us navy people and i've met a
few of the military pilots in the states
in one time or another and i must say
i would put i certainly trust my lies my
life with them you know they know what
they're doing um of course have been
reportedly been reporting these
unidentified flying vehicles and it's
this thing which is only in today's
paper said apparently nasa
is going to do well it's become involved
and if you start going into this area i
mean most people are reaching for the
off button as fast as possible but these
guys these guys
seem to have seen things which just are
impossible
so are they figments of our imagination
i don't know
but you if you hear the voiceover from
the cockpits
i love listening to these voiceovers
okay so sorry i'm not quite sure where
you're landing well what i'm trying to
say is i'm sorry i think i'm not being
necessarily oblique about this it is
that uh you you have a steady sort of
mainstream science which says there are
extraterrestrials of course and they
they will come rest assured they will
come in peace and all rest fed and then
people start going into all that all the
sort of ufo business alien abductions
all this sort of stuff uh which you know
i i don't think is is got anything to do
with extraterrestrials at all okay but
on the other hand we have some we have
some navy pilots
who are documenting these fast-moving
objects which are conceivably either a
russian or a chinese or somebody else's
technology
but if they're not then what on earth
are they
yeah and the fact that the pentagon your
your government and nasa at least are
willing to say well we can have a
conversation about this and it may turn
out you know it's some atmospheric
phenomena we don't recognize you know
i'm not saying it's you know beyond
explanation
but it it's a sort of reminder perhaps
that you know
the things aren't quite as
straightforward as we would like them to
be
right but but just so i'm i'm clear on
on where you are coming down your your
guess is or your most your biggest
credence is just on
there aren't any other technologically
advanced
alien civilizations out there
as we would recognize as you'd recognize
it okay so our thing is again and reason
enough is because we tend to extrapolate
existing things and of course we have a
lot of fun about
steam engines which couldn't go faster
than 20 miles per hour because everybody
burst into flames or whatever or
supersonic flight but in another sort of
respect actually those sort of
constraints are are somewhat better
understood and then as in fact uh we
discussed very briefly a little bit
earlier about computers which can do go
and chess
and so the idea is that you know rather
than sending delicate protoplasm to the
far reaches of the galaxy you send some
sort of ai
well
i'm not sure it's going to be a great
deal of use because they they don't know
how to think
certainly yeah
you need you need a human there and i s
sorry go on you you are so big fun well
no no i was i was just gonna i mean we
are uh
we've been talking for a while and we
haven't gotten to the juicy stuff that i
want to get to because you have a
perspective on
why it makes sense to you that we might
be the only uh advanced civilization in
our observable universe that might rub
some of your scientific colleagues the
wrong way
i'm afraid it might
i'm not i'm not i'm not doing this to
irritate people very far from it
um it it it it is i think i mean when
fermi asked that question in los alamos
um the the gist was probably what is the
feasibility of interstellar travel and
it could be that that actually really is
a quarantine zone it may be that
whatever however hard we try it just is
impossible and if that's the case and i
i can think of various science fiction
stories which have explained how you get
around these and all the rest of it
but what i'm really trying to do is uh
the far back of my mind is trying to say
you know what is so special about
ourselves which animals do not possess
what as we discuss briefly with regard
to capacity for abstraction which goes
far beyond mathematics of course because
you know i'm no i'm no great reader of
poetry but a little poetry i do read
is it on it can unhinge me
in terms of conveying meanings which a
novel will never do you know
15 lines can
put you in a completely different
perspective right and i find that
remarkable i mean people tend to take it
for granted i i just you know i
sometimes have to put down my gin and
tonic it's that it's that serious i do
pick it up very quickly afterwards
[Laughter]
thank goodness so uh but okay so i mean
to
go back to the controversies that we
started with um you know there is a
controversy outside of professional
evolution about evolution versus
creationism especially here in the
united states we've had a whole big
thing right but there's also kind of a
middle ground and i don't want to hide
it i want to i want to bring it out here
uh there are i have a good friend don
page who is a cosmologist do you know
don do you know i don't i don't know i'm
afraid he's a very good uh cosmologist a
collaborator of stephen hawking etc he's
also an evangelical christian born again
christian and he was at a conference
with a fellow cosmologist and the fellow
cosmologist said
in all good humor right why are you here
why can't you just say god did it why
are you still being a cosmologist and he
had a very articulate and sensible
response to that so if i understand
correctly you're in a similar situation
vis-a-vis evolution that you know you
study evolution scientifically but when
it comes to sort of the meaning of the
universe you're not a purely
materialistic guy
that's exactly correct but even i think
amongst nearly all biologists there's
there's a slight unease with any sort of
what we call a t loss and so they sort
of you know they think that these
animals can't you know they don't have
purpose today or they wouldn't
understand purpose any point in fact i
think that actually ironically turns out
to be the case
but indeed with your colleague don page
i mean
if one's going to have a theology which
has got a god which is interfering
continuously then that's not going to be
a very rich theology right but you're
going to have to discuss that from a
theological viewpoint and you could also
step back as a has been argued and this
is not not a defense for christianity as
it is but to the first approximation the
the roots at least european science were
very much based in in in christian
europe especially in paris and oxford
and the reason was or so i read is that
they realized that the world was open to
interrogation and they were perfectly
comfortable it was god's world which was
open to interrogation but even so it was
something which was rationally
constructed it wasn't arbitrary and
therefore it wasn't something where in
most other civilizations at one point or
another if there was a causality it was
magic
i was
just a crucial difference yeah and i was
very interested to learn i had known for
a long time that isaac newton was
extremely religious and put a lot of his
intellectual effort into studying the
bible and so forth uh but he was
actually a believer in an
interventionist god he he was smart
enough to realize that given his own
laws of motion
the solar system couldn't last forever
one of the planets would throw away the
others through gravitational interaction
so he imagined that god continually
intervened to keep the solar system on
track and i i take at that in the case
of evolution there's sort of two ways to
go for a theist right there's the idea
that god just set everything up and made
the rules but then nature obeys those
rules but there's also a way that you
could imagine god
guiding the course of evolution do you
have strong feelings about those that
dichotomy
oh i have a strong feeling against the
second option yes very much so because
that's something which as you say goes
dangerously close to intelligent design
or creationism of which you know i i i
could begin to shout i mean i will have
no i have no truck with us at all right
um
but
the the the view that in a sense you
know the the you know the cliche of the
of the fire and the equations and all
the rest of it you know what is it which
instantiates the entire universe not
only to develop its physical structures
once or another and we could i wouldn't
go in that area because i simply don't
know anything about it but you know
martin reese's areas and many other
people about the various fine-tunings
and so forth and i will understand these
things are not clear-cut either for very
many good reasons um but one could sort
of say if you're making a universe which
as i've said elsewhere sort of if you
like self fractifies
in in sense it engenders its own
creativity
but then blow me down right at the end
of the day who turns out but a sapient
species
which actually understands what
creativity is
and you could then say well the massive
category mistake they fell into was to
say because we are creative there must
be a creator
but i myself would say well in point of
fact the very fact that we have
uh this
capacity of jrr tolkien called it the
sub sub creation
is actually that richness we have in
your mathematics or that cosmology or
that music
is a very dim reflection
of the creativity of god
um and that that seems to me and people
say well you just you know you're
hedging one way or the other you're not
coming out in you know you're not
putting your cards on the table but in a
certain way i'd say well i'm entitled to
do that you know these things are not
straightforward
on that much we absolutely agree i mean
let me ask and you know feel free to
answer as much or little as you want but
when it comes to believing in god or
theism as a ontological stance toward
the world do you do you get there from a
similar set of reasoning that you get to
your belief in science and evolution or
are there different
considerations that come in
i i think there are different
considerations in as much as if for the
sake of argument you are christians as
it happens i am then one can certainly
interrogate the historical records
and
and i don't speak new testament greek
and that sort of business but even so
there's a very rich field there and one
would be willing to argue and point the
fact that the the historical narratives
there are actually
reasonably trustworthy but other people
would say that's nonsense so we need to
go down in that particular but more
particularly it is um
this question you know where does my my
imagination come from you know why do i
find myself in some parts of the world
which are just staggeringly beautiful
uh in a rather unexpected way not just
tourist sites and they can be in
surprisingly mundane ways and also i
mean again this is a very especially
because the ghastly things going on in
the ukraine and other things but you
know and this is a standard argument
against belief in god and very recently
so is how do these dreadful things
happen right
and my own sense of suggestion elsewhere
the so-called topic of theodicy you know
what that why is evil allowed to
flourish
and having
rather too much information now about
european history in the last 100 years
you know it just you cannot believe your
eyes in the 1930s you sort of see this
train wreck coming towards you and you
kept on screaming to people don't you
see what's happening and there it just
went straight on to catastrophe
but it's no comfort to anybody in any
sense who suffered one way or another
where it's an unexpected brain tumor
loss of a child you know all the
terrible things which happen
but my own sense is that actually it's
even worse to have a material universe
where this is simply meaningless
then at least having some prospect
of it being sorted out
and that's going to give no comfort to
all the people who experiences you know
i think about what happened in poland in
from 1942 you know from 1940 onwards you
know it's just heartbreaking yeah
well yeah so i mean i do feel the pull
of that even though i'm completely
atheist myself but uh you know i i'm an
atheist who believes that
following nietzsche you know once if you
stop believing in god that's not the end
of your journey like there's a whole
bunch of questions that you're now faced
with that you that you thought you had
answers to before um but let me ask this
and i think i know the answer but i want
to let you put in your words does this
belief that you have in the existence of
god setting things up have any effect on
how you do the science how you think
about tracing out the path of evolution
and so forth or is it you know once you
believe that god set it up it's your job
just like it's richard dawkins's job to
figure out exactly what happened along
the way
well believe it or not in this
particular context i agree with richard
dawkins which if you ever listen to this
might surprise him there we go
first of all i don't make any great
claims to be a particularly competent
scientist but it is simply that most
scientists as they go through their
career
tend to think a bit more widely
and they realized that things which you
know when i've did my early work in the
smithsonian institution and even when
you know more recently doing a lot of
work in china it's really been great
but i don't want to keep on doing that
forever you know it's that's good i did
it fairly well at the time um and and
more i sort of get more and more
intrigued about you know partly just
looking at one's own history how did i
end up being here where where is this
imagination which i i'm so lucky to
possess
come from and it could be completely
delusional you know it may simply be a
series of sort of artifacts and category
errors but i don't think so
okay but certainly so yeah so from
sorry i beg your pardon i mean from the
perspective of you know studying
evolution i i don't sort of say you know
well
if i can see the footprint of or the
handprint of god in this i'll feel if
someone has done a better job absolutely
not yeah okay good interesting um okay
so to wrap things up then i want to go
back i wasn't expecting this to come up
but it did and it's an intriguing thing
that could be a podcast of its own the
role of slightly non-orthodox ideas in
science uh so you you asked me if i um
had experienced this myself sure right
you know uh there is
i think that i want to recognize two
things at once so i'd like to hear your
your take on it on the one hand the way
that we do science and academia and
universities and the establishment has
been amazingly successful in many ways
right i mean we get a lot of science
done
on the other hand it's at the expense of
shutting down certain lines of inquiry
uh um
inventing certain kinds of conventional
wisdom and following them to the end and
those who fit into the dominant paradigm
have it a lot easier and on the third
hand when you say you know i don't want
to fit into the dominant paradigm i want
to you know be bold and creative
everyone will say oh sure that's great
until you tell them exactly the way in
which you want to be bold and creative
i'm like oh no no not that way we didn't
we didn't want that so i i actually am a
little bit up in the air about how to
balance all of these considerations
against each other and therefore it's
not really a question but you know over
to you what do you think about these
issues
well i i i share very much all those
perspectives um and but i think in a way
and again this is slightly
dangerous territory because we do think
that science does have some degree of
independent objectivity to it which has
got nothing to do with where you were
born or what you think or what you
believe and i i think that that is
correct as it so happens on the other
hand
we know perfectly well that cultures do
change and evolve
and there are cultures
and societies which i would suggest are
more propitious
to open and free thinking
and this you can see it's going to lead
in some very very dangerous territory
with almost no effort at all
and there are other ones which tend to
be far more inward-looking
and we can think of historical examples
to do this and again there's you know a
whole set of baggage associated with
this because apart from anything else
you know when you have a scientific
solution to something which incidentally
happens to lead to the destruction of a
city
then you know that i once again or as i
said much earlier all bets are off
but my sense at the moment in terms of
let's say western universities
is that they are
less encouraging
for speculative thinking
and in fact quite frequently you know
if you're really lucky you know you had
a series of really splendidly strong gin
and tonics and people say well off the
record you know and they will very
frequently say well actually you know i
think you're onto something or i had
this really weird experience or this
really strange thing happened to me in
all the restaurants i don't i can't
explain it and certainly i can't see any
way in fitting these into a simple
paradigm
at all and as you know i mean there are
people
on the orthodox side right on the
fringes of this people like rupert
sheldrake for instance and everybody
says well for goodness sake you know
you know but he is a trained scientist
and you might say well he's just you
know gone too far of peace to be
believable
but if one assumes that in the end
uh there are no limits to knowledge and
i don't think there are they point it
back and if one assumes in fact that in
a way science is the capacity not so
much to confirm things that's rather
boring but actually and i i i don't
think i've got can i ever get this story
quite right but i had i wouldn't say the
privilege but when i was a very young
research fellow in my college in
cambridge um paul dierak who was a
fellow of my college came back from
florida in the summer
and uh i had the you know i happened to
sit beside him a couple of times at
lunch and he was there many many stories
about dirac as you know a man of very
few words
one of his stories i'm told i don't know
if it's true or not is some young
student at some conference said well
professor dirac um could you please
explain this slightly more simply and
direct was famous for these long
silences so he said please could you
explain this a bit more simply and then
jirac after about a minute said no
but he sort of
if i understand graham farmlow's
biography of him he he sort of found
this sort of not number but you know
this thing which was essential to
explaining what he wanted i think to do
with anti-mass or something like that
you're the expert on this sort of sign
but here's something plucked out of thin
air which in a way
analogous to the complex number we
talked about earlier suddenly has
enormous traction
and for all we know actually beyond it
there's a mathematics where this is
utterly trivial
you know it doesn't really matter
anymore it's a it's a plus sign
but even a plus sign going back to
animals is something which they'll never
understand right
so
yeah i feel very strongly in the sense
that
uh the way we teach the way we deal with
university research does not necessarily
always encourage imagination
it does
yeah and we would like it to and uh i'll
just thank you again for poking our
brains to think about things in slightly
different ways climbing convoy morris
thanks very much for being on the
windscape podcast my great pleasure
thank you
[Music]
you